people are the ROI of life
I couldn't believe more in like the
people aspect of all this there's
nothing you learned for many but I don't
give up how hands-on or how much you
actually you've done none of it is even
remotely close to as ry+ as like the
people you meet the skills are
commoditized there's a lot of people I'm
gonna be able to do what you do it might
be tough at a young age you might it's
tough at an older age like you may not
be extroverted it might feel weird to
say hello but like in your last week or
what have you liked as much cafeteria
time as much like hello as much as you
can like muster up literally hi um I
believe in it the most the high arm in
the elevator couldn't push you more if
you get anything out of this like that
one random hello that this Mustard's out
could literally be the whole thing just
could just is actually I think that's my
advice and we've talked about this a
little bit in the Vayner sports stuff
like that's my advice for when you go
back to school probably my favorite talk
I've given the last couple years was to
the UF's to the USC football team you
know I speak a lot I do this a lot and
you can always tell when you hit a nerve
there's a moment in that USC football
talk where I tell them I'm like you guys
are idiots you think you're so cool cuz
you're on the USC football team
meanwhile 99% of you this is the
highlight of your life straight up for
90% of you this is the greatest year of
your life right now that's just the
truth you can be mad at me can be sad at
me you can think I'm stupid
telling you straight to your faces for
80 to 90% of you this is it this is the
pinnacle so you better squeeze the
like what you're too cool for somebody
you got to listen your headphones and
put your hoodie on can't say hello like
like I'm desperate for the guy that's
thinking that to just say yo you need to
go the other way and you think you're
cool and you're putting your beats by
dre on and your buddy and not looking
anybody in the eye and think you're
somebody and your life's gonna suck for
the next 50 years because you didn't say
hello to the kids sitting next to you
who went on to run Disney to me the ROI
of things like college are the people
people are the game in life that's how
it life actually plays out that is the
best piece of advice I can give you like
when you go back to school like say
hello to everybody people as people are
the are alive life so it's cool that you
got like better at analytics or like
real life experience of talking to a
client commodity you would have gotten
at some point anyway whether you can do
it or not cool but like actually
becoming friends with each other in here
like actually not like when the slack
channel dies like everybody in here can
help the other person potentially in a
real significant way you know eighty
percent of you especially if you don't
get into this company we're gonna have
jobs you eat right out of school and the
other person's gonna have something they
like and they could be the one
recommending you in people questions
[Music]